قد تكون إحدى الأدوات لوقف الجائحة التالية
هي مياه الصرف الصحي الداخلية التي سمعتها أن
الاسم الرسمي الصحيح هو مراقبة مياه الصرف
وهي طريقة
فعالة لاكتشاف الحالات المبكرة قبل أن تتحول
إلى فاشيات الآن.
تم استخدامه
لعقود من الزمن لاكتشاف الانتشار
المبكر لأمراض مثل الكوليرا وشلل الأطفال
مؤخرًا ، وقد تم استخدامه لتتبع استخدام العقاقير غير المشروعة
، والإنفلونزا الشائعة حتى تساعد في
تحديد معدلات الإصابة بالسرطان جيدًا الآن ، وقد
اكتسبت أهمية جديدة تمامًا مع
فيروس كوفيد 19 وإليك
سبب الفيروس  التي تسبب مرض كوفيد يمكن أن تظهر
في البراز لمدة تصل إلى أسبوع قبل
أن تظهر على شخص ما أعراض قد تكون
قبل أن يقرر الناس إجراء
الاختبار وهو أمر حساس حقًا لأنه
يمكن أن يلتقط أصغر كمية من الفيروسات
وأنظمة الصرف الصحي عن طريق
اختبار  المواد الوراثية للفيروسات الآن
يمكن أن يمنح هذا النوع من المعلومات المستشفيات
وقتًا إضافيًا للاستعداد يمكن أن يعطي
الأفراد انتباهًا لأخذ
p  تعتبر الاحتياطات بالإضافة إلى مراقبة مياه الصرف الصحي
أقل تكلفة بكثير من إجراء
الآلاف من اختبارات cova الفردية ،
وهنا كيف
يتم جمع العينات من فتحة المجاري أو إزالة
حطام محطة معالجة مياه الصرف الصحي
ثم يتم
تركيز العينة وإرسالها إلى المختبر
لاختبارها.  دقيقة للغاية بحيث
يمكنها تحديد المتغيرات المحددة التي
بدأت في الانتشار في المجتمع ،
وهذه هي الطريقة التي اكتشف بها المسؤولون لأول مرة
متغير omicron في كاليفورنيا وتكساس
حتى قبل أن يبدأ الناس في اختبار
إيجابية للمتغير بأنفسهم
وعندما يختبر الناس هذا بشكل أقل وأقل
تكرارًا  ستصبح أداة
مفيدة بشكل متزايد ،
لا يتم استخدام هذا النوع من مراقبة مياه الصرف الصحي في
كل مكان حتى الآن ، لكن شبكة مواقع مراقبة الأقراص المضغوطة
موجودة الآن في
40 ولاية على الأقل ، وقد بدأت في التوسع إلى
أبعد من ذلك الهدف النهائي للمساعدة في
بناء صورة أفضل عن  كيف
ينتشر الفيروس التاجي في جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، فكر في الأمر على أنه
نظام إنذار مبكر دائمًا  perating في
الخلفية
[موسيقى]